a big picture about how different parts
of the brain interact with each other to
generate coherent behaviors during
courtship and aggression and
specifically the the flexible the
cockpit aspect of the behavior we still
don't know exactly what is the neural
Maxim's for that and that's something
that my lab is really interested in
surveillance is arousal the two building
blocks of elementary emotions can
actually be accessible in Joseph's lab
well so in addition to all the cognitive
studies they were in doing right now and
I would say dress tough I consider it as
a hydrogen model for social cognition
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki on we are on
site at the beautiful Westlake
University in Hangzhou China we are now
going to be talking about the neural
mechanisms of social cognition we have
dr. yi soon joining us on the show hi
you thank you so much for coming on the
show really appreciate it yeah I'm very
excited for this conversation for those
who don't know Yi's background he's a
neuroscientist physical chemist engineer
and professor at Westlake University
pioneering novel methods in functional
brain imaging focusing on the neural
mechanisms of social cognition and you
can find the links in the bio below you
let's start things off with one of our
favorite questions we like asking our
guests what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world yeah that's a
very good question I think the director
is moving towards inflammation explosion
and I think part of the words about the
dynamics of information flow so a key
question is how information I integrated
and those involves integration of
information through say computers in the
physical world or information and Brent
and that's why I'm interested in this
social way information flows and the
information flow dynamics of things that
make the dynamics of information flows
yeah exactly okay and then specifically
with you know especially biology has
this social behavior between creatures
that then enables information flows and
to do specific objective functions like
yeah like reproduction or gathering food
and resources yeah yeah go over here
there's a plenty of food over here
foraging behavior yeah yeah yeah
interesting and then we as a billion
creatures also have our dynamics of
information flow that enable us to say
well maybe you should move to the city
because there's more opportunity there's
more efficiency and there's more wealth
to be made that type of stuff and we
tell these stories about people going to
the city and finding opportunity and
stuff like that do you do you frequently
make these abstract leaps from
biological communicative processes for
social cognition which we're going to
dive really deep into and abstractly
metaphor give metaphors for how we as a
civilization of humans behave
that's a pretty tough question so these
days I'm generally concerned was you
know the internal representations and
things like that being animal brains how
do we make metaphors between abstract
aspects of how a brain works compared to
the operations information flow things
like that in the real world I think I
think my study in the simplest systems
like small brains like just a flow plan
that we study eventually help us
understand much more complicated real
world or although human brains things
like that yeah yeah that that part to
your research is probably the most
interesting for me is once you
understand the neural mechanisms of
social cognition and the internal
representation then you can maybe begin
to start abstracting up from a fruit fly
to the mammals and human brains human
brains and then all of a sudden we have
a better understanding of how we work
and how our society works and so that's
my favorite pardon let's do let's jump
into your journey so who where were you
born
who were you as a kid growing up and how
did you get interested in science I got
interested in science in the family
because when I was a kid my pet my
parents were educators then they gave me
a lot of different toys to to play with
importantly they they gave me they asked
me to create toys and I can play with
the toys that I created and through that
process I can come up with things that
I'm interested in which are the toys and
the technologies to build this toys and
I think that really eventually we
to my career in science and technology
Wow and this was in the jung-soo
province yes it's a Joseph province club
there it goes through
jojo's province that we're living in now
so once you started making your own toys
and tools and stuff that kind of led you
into your interest in engineering and
then that got you into that was that
your bachelor's was at the school of
mechanical engineering and automation in
Beijing University of Aeronautics and
Astronautics so walk us through going to
doing your bachelor's and getting
interested in engineering further and
then also going starting to get into
your PhD let's start going on the track
yeah that was a pretty long journey so I
was Origin interest in engineering
because I saw engineering was cool
actually I still think engineering is
very cool
so after graduation I actually went to
the industry I was working in companies
that were producing information
technologies we bring a lot of
programming and a certain point I
realize that it's it's very important to
study instead of mechanical things or
like physical things I want to get
better understanding of ourselves so I
went to graduate school I was studying
things that have some connections with
like gooding tools and help us better
understand how we are where we are and
how we do yeah so that worse about my
PhD it was actually in physical
chemistry were building
nano technology tools that eventually
can help us to study biological systems
as one of the applications but by the
end of my PhD study I became more and
more interested in the brand a partner
is in the works because we were we were
devising technologies to record the
activity for
electrical activity and one of the
applications was of course to record
from the activity of the brain cells so
from there I became interested in I
start to read neuroscience papers and
start to read near science textbooks and
I went to new science courses and finds
this wow this is much more interesting
than wants to study so eventually I
moved on to neuroscience and I I did a
postdoc in Howard Hughes Medical
Institute and then I was working on the
rhesus specialists there for about six
years time really got me dive into
understanding the brain and technologies
for understanding the branch bus yeah
it's interesting hearing about how you
had this engineering background that
then was like well I want to know how
life works I want to know how the life
works and so that kind of gave you this
really good footing for dissecting and
diving deeper into biology with an
engineering mindset and then this
fascination with reading brain cell
activity and yeah yeah I like this a lot
okay and so then that would that PhD
happened physical chemistry and
nanotechnology at the National Center
for nanoscience and technology Chinese
Academy of Sciences me and then you went
to do this postdoc at Howard Hughes
Medical Institute which actually I was
recently learning is just one of the
most well funded research institutes in
the world and it's really cool that um
there's lots of people actually from
West Lake that got a chance to be there
and then do their research there so
let's start talking about that so you
were doing optical probes that report
electrical activity through fluorescence
okay let's walk us down what you were
doing there and what that is apparent is
very important recorded activity the
brand that's the way you really
understand how the brain works right and
one of the first technology was to
record through electrical recordings the
very famous patch clamp recording
technology they really allow us to
to get a sense of the activity of
individual cells at a very high temporal
resolution of course the problem is the
print the brand doesn't work as
individual cells the brand works as in
your network composed of many many
actually millions billions of neurons
right so ready to understand how does
your network generate activity patterns
and eventually to behavior we need to
understand the activity of a population
of cells simultaneously and and that
acquires technologies to recording not
just ones that were designed but many
many cells at the time so there was
while we were looking for optical
technology because for electrical
technology there are certain ways to
record more than one style but those
technologies doesn't tell you exactly
which cell recording from to hear the
sound of many many cells is like a
cocktail party but doesn't really tell
which one is which so we designed this
probes which are built upon the
fluorescence technology it's green
fluorescent protein which is a protein
that for us all the time so we did some
protein engineering so that the protein
wouldn't throw ass all the time instead
of for us whenever yours your activity
and the way we translating your activity
into the fluorescence is for calcium
because we know from other studies that
neural activity changes leads to calcium
concentration changes with individual
cells so we design probes that can
detect calcium changes real time okay so
that really is two-step process one is
from electrical activity to calcium the
other one is from Towson to fluorescence
changes and all happens was pretty high
temporal resolution and with the help of
imaging technology in
do that recording for many cells
simultaneously Wow okay so from
electrical activity to calcium changes
from calcium changes to fluorescence and
then being able to image not only a
single neuron but a network of neurons
that then give you an idea of behavior
right okay cool cool okay now where else
along the way to Westlake were you
starting to think about this pioneering
these novel methods and functional brain
imaging what were you thinking of when
you were at Howard Hughes what were you
trying to to understand a deeper level
of these neural mechanisms and then how
did you end up transitioning to this a
professorship here at Wesley yeah so
when I were at how are he actually
genius at campus I was interesting two
things one is the optical probes for
recording the activity the other one is
about how we use his probes to really
understand the under the operation of
the brain so one of the things were I
was really interesting is about the
selection process like we make
selections we make decisions all the
time in our lives right so I was trying
to understand this from some really
simplified power lines so we were
studying how the fruit fly Drosophila
melanogaster which is a great model
system because it's more accessible
brand but still a rich repertoire of
behavior how do they make decisions so I
were using very simple visual
stimulations and recording the activity
in the brain using the probes that we
developed not just green communicator G
can six G chem seven but also rat
calcium indicators a jar
one jar came along we were doing this
simultaneous to color to photo imaging
so that we can record from different
channels that are from different
populations in your own zone spatially
intermingled that tell us about the
representations and the transformations
of the information of that
representation of the brand that
eventually lead us to the fly to makes a
decision to say dedicate engage in a
specific object amount of out of out of
several yeah so that was the study area
studying in a simplified paradigm and I
wanted to study this decision-making
process a more natural realistic
paradigm scenario and I think the
ultimate natural situation is our
society right because we all live in a
society we have to make decisions we
make choices all the time
in our society and I think Josephine is
still a great model system and at that
time Westlake was establishing it was
actually it was still under active
construction so I have experience of
working in newly established
institutions I got my PhD from nano
science and technology National Center
for nanoscience and technology which
were established about a little over 10
years ago and that was also the time
when junior research campus of Howard
Hughes Medical Institute established in
Nashville Virginia in suburban areas DC
and I I think have a great experience
working in those newly established
institutions because of the excitement
an affair on campus and there is one of
the driving forces why I was choosing
was fake
out of either places yeah you have the
magic of all the different departments
here that are coming together to push
the ed frontiers of some right the
interdisciplinary environment here it's
a small but still highly diversified
institution yes yes okay so the focus
now is on neural mechanisms of social
cognition internal representation
internal representation has a couple
subsections behavior anatomy imaging
start walking us through what this is
yeah so so the way we study the neural
mechanism is social behavior first I
have to have behavior paradigms that
help us to dissect specific aspects to
basically define a questions right to
translate behavior which is highly
variable in two very specific questions
you can address who is technology with
to is in your size and that's about
behavior so we have paradigms that are
involving free beheading flies the Flies
are afraid to do whatever they want to
do and from there we record their
behavior record they're all aspects of
the behaviors or sound their emotion and
then do a lot of analysis and from there
we get specific perspectives we find we
find clues about how they make decisions
how they learn from each other say and
how do they recognize each other and
from there we do more controlled
behavior experiments those more
controlled behavior expense would tell
us something about how they perceive
others and that really the hallmarks of
or indications of internal
representations in their brain to get at
the interrupts intentions in the brand
we first need to get a picture a static
picture of the brand because we first
need to know the basics
like if you want to understand the
behavior of Hangzhou we know about the
dynamics of the traffic we first need to
know about the roads rise it's a network
of roads in Hangzhou before we dive into
the dynamics of the traffic so in a
similar way we we first need to get an
anatomical basis with just static
pictures of the brand before we get to
the more dynamic aspect which is about
the physiology so there we apply the
technology the optical probes that we
developed early on to record the
activity the brand we will try to do all
these commandments in one animal so the
animal is you know doing specific
behavior tasks and then record their
activity and from there we can find the
neural correlates of internal
representations that are kind of
modeling their perception of others yes
okay so let's continue this example
where we have the dress off of a fruit
fly that is in it in a guess of chambers
yeah right so let's explain these these
chambers so you you are doing things
like watching it with the camera mm-hmm
and you're recording that data yeah and
you're also recording the audio yeah of
the Flies
okay and then you are also then having
another fruit fly join it yeah okay and
then you're observing how they interact
yes so we have two fruit flies just like
we have on this couch to humans mm-hmm
and there's a camera watching us just
like there would be a dreamer watching I
from Friday and then there's a recording
right knowledge
the audio happening yeah and so now what
are the fruit fly saying to each other
mm-hmm what are they talking about and
how do you make neural correlates of
specific audio frequencies and
wavelengths and etc to what they can
very good questions so our communication
is a response to specific situations
right so we say specific things because
we learn to deliver specific message to
to change the situation say we sit here
and I say hello because we want to make
better connections right so the approach
we study this problem is to to
categorize recordings the patterns of
the sound and then we find the context
where specific types of communication of
of patterns generated right so you say
what I mean so we first record the audio
use of the Flies and then we categorize
into different types for because first
we need to know what they're
communicating and then the second
question is how why they're
communicating that they communicating
that response to specific contacts
because say another fly we're skating
them and acting for positive information
or there's something like they need to
communicate by the environment so we we
take out the specific time stamps of
specific types of communication pattern
and then we study through the videos and
audios about the context and we try to
see if there is a correlation between
the context and the specific patterns of
communication
yes that's how we understand what the
message is are actually being delivered
because you know we records a sound can
only knows a physical acoustic property
of the pattern but we don't know exactly
what the message what the meanings that
those communications are right we tried
to deliver we try to understand derive
the meanings by looking at the context
the recent history yes so then we do
something like we take the right start
we we start in a sense building out a
library of different audio recordings
and video analogs through those audios
yeah yeah so now I have a library and
there's type a Type C type Q audio
record dictionary or dictionary yeah I
like that
okay okay so there's this library or
dictionary happening and then then
there's a an audio and a video component
that goes to every type in the
dictionary mm-hmm and then now you've
built out a catalog hmm so this catalog
is happening mm-hmm and then how do you
then say let's map type a to specific
neural activity or type D to neural
activity so we can understand what
social cognitive processes are right
right so that's about how we move you
know free behaving animals to more
restrict hazard preparations where you
know the fire unions are flying or it's
walking on a bowl that it's restricted
its had fixed it's important to have
fixation because we can do physiology
do calcium imaging right using the
optical products we do out to look at
their brand and then we try to simulate
the environment that we just discover
right so from the behavior studies I
mentioned before we know the context of
specific patterns so we tried to replay
the context and then we look at they
actively branded so we try to see what
was going on or the interpretations for
the context and then what are the
interpretations that are predictive of
the patterns of sound that they're gonna
deliver so it's very important that we
study the behavior and physiology at the
same time yeah okay so you're doing a
couple things you have a chamber for the
fruit flies where you're doing where
you're doing video and audio recordings
in a free moving space and you enter in
second fruit flies do you ever enter in
third and fourth fruit flies how many at
most of you guys look I mean the
paradigms how many total fruit flies do
you let hang out in the chamber to see
what happens with their group dynamics
oh we have collective behavior as
composed of many many flies we have a
whole range of different studies
interests from - flies to many so
there's a dictionary for - flies and
there's a dictionary 4 3 4 5
I think the dictionary for two flies is
probably kind of general for arbitrary
numbers or communications yeah we don't
know yet yeah yeah although there are
interesting dynamics that change when
whether there's a third person in this
conversation right one fourth per second
then the four person conversation could
break into two two percent conversations
and that two person combination could
change over time yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're exactly built
they'll start talking to those
mm-hmm yeah exactly okay so okay so
there's a chamber one that's happening
and then there's also this you call it a
partial tethering mm-hmm okay so the
let's talk about the anatomy of the
fruit fly yeah it's very important to
too so I actually skip the anatomy part
because it seems like after studying the
behavior we go directly to the
physiology which is not really true
so after studying behavior we basically
have no idea what's going on in the
brain so I have to know the nearest
substrate of specific behavior because
not all the brain is used for all the
behavior so we do some behavior genetic
study to find potential candidate
circuits for specific behavior and then
we use anatomic approaches which you can
call it near a circuit study whatever
connect on things like that to
understand a static picture of the brand
that probably underlying this behavior
yes so with the anatomy we're doing
things like let's see this visual brain
then right sit thorax yeah which is
connected to the six legs and the two
wings and you tether it specifically to
the thorax to make its abet the fruit
fly in a sense can still move on there's
a ball so this is again this is
different than the chamber mm-hmm so it
can move on this ball but that the brain
it's not moving so so much that you
can't properly image the brain over time
in space mm-hmm so it's enabling you to
give and this is where I wanted to also
ask you before we used to just take a
dead piece of brain tissue and image
and now we're keeping the brain tissue
in the organism while it's alive while
it's tethered and imaging it so it's
giving us a more real understanding of
social cognition rather than just yeah a
dead piece of tissue right right yeah so
the early studies those about about the
brain basically neurophysiology or is
done to a large stand on dissected
brands actually people also do culture
capture neurons dissociated culture
neurons for cellular mechanism so those
studies are great for studying a lot of
molecular some of the synaptic
physiology but they're very difficult to
to recapitulate the actual alarm the
animals are engaged in and also when is
dissected a lot of connections are cut
right so the the physiological states of
the of the brain is is different we
don't know exactly how different they
are so people moved from dissected
brands to in vivo studies but people
Anisa tie the animal so that there's no
movement it's very important get rid of
the movement because movement or
detrimental for a lot of physiological
studies say physiology electrophysiology
or imagine but still the animal is not
in a normal physiological state and in
size this is not a normal physiological
state so people start to do a weak but
not behaving so people try to tether the
animal as much as possible
and more than wake and we can do the
recordings but we don't know exactly the
animal is thinking about right there
could be daydreaming about whatever
their day dreaming about so after that
we start to do physiology in behaving
animals tether behaving animals so that
really gives us
a context to study the dynamics of the
brand because the animal is attending to
very specific features in the
environment and they're processing those
features environment and they're
generating specific behaviors so we can
look at the dynamics of the brand when
the behavior results a cracked and it
can also compare those two when the
behavior facts are wrong
so that really tell us about how does a
brand solve the problems that a Meserve
are trying to interfere out yeah okay so
where does this dictionary or library
catalog that we were talking about
before with audio and video
representations of social behavior how
does that begin to be related to when
you have the second the second
experiments that we're talking about
where the fruit fly is tethered and it's
on the ball and then you have a couple
other very interesting additions to the
experiment happening you have a a
virtual reality that the fruit fly is
basically and with the with a display
that is constant if the fruit fly moves
on the ball the display changes and so
it gives a you know a false
representation of of control of if it
actually being in it in a fake
environment and and then how does then
the fruit fly on that in that tethered
secondary environment how does that give
you when you're actually looking for
these these neural correlates and you're
doing the microscopy on the brain how
does it then in that environment have
the relations to that first and
where you were doing the catalogues of
audio and video and and social behavior
yeah so so the first one is more about
in a more natural context we try to same
post through the possibility space of
the communication the vocabulary the
dictionary of the five and from there we
pick some of the things that we think
are more interesting some of the
patterns of communication that are
critical for specific behavior say they
try to deliver a message like a mail fly
saying to a female fly I love you or am
alpha saying to another female fly that
I hate you we take those pieces and we
focus on those pieces and we try to
devise simulations that tell us more
about the details of that communication
and how does how are those decisions
like love or hate made in the bird so so
this is a much more controlled
experiments that we do tethered behavior
since the first one is about generating
hypotheses in and finding and finding
all kinds of phenomenology and second
one is to specifically look at the
mechanism for a few critically important
some of the most important key points
during social communication and social
interactions okay so if in the chamber
you see a an interaction that is that
you can run a pattern recognition on a
lot of people are using AI for these
types of purposes they're looking at
tons and tons of image or tons and tons
of audio and they're finding okay here's
a pattern to a specific thing in our
dictionary to type a yeah we hypothesize
that that could be and I love you let's
say okay a mating call of sorts okay for
reproduction and maybe that can even be
better seen by if they decide to have
sex
afterward the fruit fly sex afterward
then you're like okay that was probably
I love you that was probably those
reproduce right right yeah okay so then
then when you take it into the second
environment you want to then do some
sort of simulated I love you to be able
to then map what's happening in the
brain during that I love you so maybe
it's like optogenetic stimulation a for
the fruit fly where it can be simulated
for that fruit fly that oh it's that
it's that I love you and then you're
mapping what's happening in the neural
architecture on the in that yeah that's
one does the same we do we use up to
genetics to activate or assign and
specific populations and neurons that
give us clues about or give us controls
over the state of the animal but we also
deliver
carefully designed quantitative
stimulations visual stimulation auditory
stimulation such things like that and we
look at we quantitatively record measure
the activity of the brain we try to
build correlations between those sensory
stimulation and inner activity and we
try to see at which stage what are the
representations for those sensory inputs
and what are the transformations between
different stages of representations and
how those sensory the percepts are
gradually transformed into categories
that facilitates decision making
yeah so so we look at it's an important
aspect of this is everything's
quantitative so actually the first stage
of free behaving behavior we talked
about early on it's also involved a lot
of quantitative analysis about the
videos actions a movement of the animals
and the audios the communications are
sound of the animals we have to do
analysis and some of the analysis are
done online so that we can have
closed-loop feedback real-time feedback
yeah what would you say are the most
common social cognitive communications
happening between fruit flies like if
you had to say that there were certain
things that were being communicated in
the dictionary or in this catalogue what
are the most popular types of
communication that they're happening
it's urgent
of course net courtship yeah parsnip is
the most frequent case because like
reproduction is just like top priority
mm-hmm yeah I think that's probably the
same across many many different species
so funny like yeah courtship is uh
because you can do foraging you can find
food on your own that you cannot
reproduce in your life or for higher
order animals it's impossible right yeah
I guess in a sense like a fruit fly can
just yeah reproduce and then maybe can
not necessarily maybe have to care so
much about its offspring like Oh am i
financially stable enough do I have
enough food to support my offspring
mm-hmm maybe it's a little bit more just
like I'm just gonna have offspring a lot
and just not necessarily have to worry
about if there's gonna be enough food or
docks for the offsprings then just kind
of let them yeah go what would be a
second most popular communication that's
happening fighting I think fighting yep
so so between mouths mouths male and
female to female Wow
they fight they fight for food they
fight for mates they fight for a lot of
things but the fighting is much more
dynamic than courtship and it's actually
compared to courtship it's pretty rare
Oh interesting
yeah so it's it's sort of graded like
they don't burst into fierce fighting
immediately there is a building up
process yeah the building up with
courtship - right there isn't yeah there
is a building up of worship it seems
like worship is more more robust yeah
yeah there's question between males as
well
okay so there's obviously a lot of
biological hierarchy of importance of
prioritization happening across
different species humans fruit flies
doesn't matter what species there's
always this kind of like hierarchy of
probably
and and for a lot of the time it's just
like reproduction is a big one but if a
fruit fly has a limited lifespan then it
needs to prioritize reproduction whereas
we have an 80-year lifespan we can
reproduce in a longer window in the mid
part of our lives or early in apart okay
okay so okay let's talk about when this
the the most common behavior is
courtship so what visual and auditory
signal processing are you doing that is
able to say oh look the male and female
are about to you know how can you
predict like courtship for happening
with like an audio signal or a video
right so so when they starting to show
signs of engagement or first they are
into each other then now will be our
intent or specific females so basically
the attention of the male will be
directed towards the female and then
start to catch up with a try and start
to chase the female and the female would
just flee and then they try to keep
doing this chasing game and if the
female is interesting the MAL the female
is slowed down that certain stage so
become receptive to the mouth it gave
them our an opportunity then the male
would start to sing a song then the
female will make a decision if she likes
this song she likes the song of the
mouth and she's ready to accept them out
and she will you know just come to a
stop and and eventually they're engaged
in Corsa copulation Wow
it's a it's a pretty Wow dynamic process
Wow yeah okay so there's a lot of you
visual and acoustic communication yes
during this interesting orientation for
and then the tasty chasing yeah and then
and attempted copulation taxi song yes
song singing yes suddenly very
interesting singing yeah Wow
so how do you guys know it's like
singing it's it's pretty obvious you can
record a sound and it's very typical
it's it's called Palestine so the POW
sounds are strongly indicated of a
courtship process Wow okay so you
literally singing and then the females
deciding whether or not the song was
good enough mm-hmm yeah and then
copulation and then offspring yeah
how quickly do they end up like like do
they end up staying together or do they
end up going and reproducing with others
they were do the latter yeah say yes
face is not monogamous anymore
yeah the Drosophila is not monogamous
and it's just constantly trying to swirl
its genes with other genes instead of
just the specific genetic code mm-hmm so
yeah I think I think in in in birds and
some of the other higher-order species
yours see monogamy social among me or
sash of monogamy more frequently yeah
yeah well because there's also
completely different dynamic biological
dynamicism to that process where you
have us which has to like raise a child
for such a long period of time and we
can't just like birth the child and then
go and like try and swirl our genes with
other
of our same species because that child
can't just go off and try and find food
itself it has to be raised and yeah yeah
yeah there's different timelines there's
different there's so many other factors
that go into this okay well yes yeah
it's very important that we try to study
those various factors that get into the
decisions during social interactions and
try to see how it is a brand weigh
different factors and eventually you
know make a choice to dedicate to a
specific decision yeah yeah there's
information integration and
decision-making or some of the similar
scientific questions that were terribly
interested in it likewise I'm so
fascinated by that that loops us all the
way to the what you were saying at the
beginning so I'm constantly taking in my
environment and I'm figuring out you
know I have like a ledger of my
environment in my internal ledger and
I'm constantly trying to figure out like
you know if my stomache ledger is low
maybe I'm gonna change my environment in
the ledger so I'm closer to food so I
get food and I like this a lot this like
dynamic game of well okay if my internal
ledger is like it's I'm getting closer
at the age of 35 maybe it's more and
more important for me to find a mate to
reproduce with and it's so interesting
that you guys ended up identifying these
neural mechanisms and internal
representations of courtship to be the
most like common and now you're stuck so
studying courtship is the LAT is your
labs most yeah well actually we're
specific interesting social cognition
there's a community of scientists that
are interested in the biological basis
the neural basis of social behavior like
worship aggression itself
and in addition on top of that there are
copies control during courtship and
aggression say there's attention there's
memory there's decision-making all those
things there's learning during those
very dynamic social behaviors social
interactions and my lab is specifically
interested in the cognitive aspects of
social behavior so we don't focus on the
funds is the basic social interaction is
the hot wired circuits of social
behavior interested in the dynamics in
the modulation in the coffee aspects
during Suraj ok so how do you then
replay how do you simulate a male
do you like literally put up on the
screen like the female fruit fly and
then the male fruit fly when you're
doing this we do we do our range of
stimulation from realistic physical
flies of different stay different states
and we also do simulated more controlled
or computer simulated stimulations yeah
for the other flies so so simulations
that then stimulate the neural activity
so that you can map credits of salt
social cognition okay and your what like
what I guess what areas of the neural
architecture of the Drosophila do you
see most engaged with courtship well at
this stage I would say pretty much you
know many many parts of the central
brain is engaged there indications for
many many different types of neurons but
we're still lacking a big picture about
how different parts of the brain
interact with each other to generate
coherent behaviors during courtship and
aggression and specifically
the flexible the cognate aspect of the
behavior we still don't know exactly
what is the neural Maxim's for that and
that's something that my lab is greatly
interested looking for the neural
mechanisms of courtship and aggression
and as our social and other social
interactions okay okay cool cool cool
right so basically the courtship the
social behavior of flies are now
stereotyped not as stereotyped as we
thought there is a quite a bit of
flexibility like flies do make choices
between say different potential mates
yes and and the aggression process the
fighting process is also highly dynamic
it's it's not something that is very
fruitful axis so that's something that
that's the kind of behavior that we it's
great interested in and your maximum for
that is where over read it interesting
okay so it would it be something like
the neural mechanisms of me looking at
potential mate number one and potential
mate number two and then me like looking
at them and trying to figure out what
the dynamic activity in the brain of
like is that one a better mate right now
or is that one a better mate right now
yeah okay and like how I switch between
those two yeah like what neural activity
is lighting up what in that
decision-making process yeah what kind
of circa architect or support that yeah
and then it could potentially
extrapolate up to our own brains when we
exactly exactly yeah so it's very
important now so the reason we study
just a flaw which is entirely different
from ourselves people wonder why we
study social cognition in such an
entirely different species the reason is
because it's a much more accessible
tractable model system so from these
studies we can know the circuit
architecture and the activity patterns
that generate the behavior of say
attention
of say memory or decision-making
learning things like that and these
knowledge ease can actually directly
translate into algorithm to help us to
design more intelligent systems directly
we don't have to we don't have to study
the human brain to do that we can learn
from any kinds of biological model
system in Drosophila I would say is
probably the most convenient system that
we have access to at the moment at the
same time the results that we learned
the principle that were in from this
simple model system will help us to
understand much more complicated system
because if we look at the history of
biology where I see a lot of this
fundamental principles were actually in
the molecular level roughly discovered
in single cell model Ogden's such as
ecoli yeast things like that and if you
look more even more broadly across the
entire scientific field say physics the
quantum mechanics we spend most of the
effort to study hydrogen right use
hydrogen model as the model for a lot of
studies in quantum mechanics so that's
the basics of you know the whole
architecture of quantum you guys and I
would say just off I consider it as a
hydrogen model for social cognition
okay okay I like that especially with
the long time scale of biological
evolution and just how neural the
neurology the nervous system inside of
creatures has been developing for such a
long time
there is almost inevitably going to be
correlates in the nervous system across
across species especially since in the
hierarchy of of decision-making like
reproduction as is it a hundred percent
common across like pretty much almost
every species has to have reproduction
in its hierarchy and likely the top
thing in its hierarchy along with food
foraging click yeah yeah yeah yeah so
then it's very possible that when you
look at like how a fruit flies
determining like mate number one versus
mate number two and like switching
between those to find out which one it
could almost kind of be like when a
woman or a man is looking at potential
mates themselves as well and like
switching like what architecture in the
brain is lighting up and also what just
like a male has a song that is played in
a sense you know we have our songs that
are played with our like our like online
profiles of ourselves like when someone
looks at our online profile in a sense
it's a song that's being played to them
about who we are are our work are our
you know our travel or our interests or
whatever and then also we have these
little micro songs that are played in
terms of like when we meet each other in
person or when we send each other
messages or emails or you can add little
smiley faces or a little winky faces or
little all different types of of
nuance to our social communication that
can then be related in some way to
people deciding whether or not we are
good mate to reproduce with yeah emotion
comes together is confidential process
yes that's the very important part of
social study social cognition as well so
when we talk about cognition is not just
limited to classic definition of
cognition it also includes emotion even
though the emotional flies live the
elusive compared to emotion in high
order species but the Flies do display
some elementary some you know very
simple forms of emotion like like or
dislike the likes and dislikes some of
them are innate someone never learned
and this response is generally
considered as valence this which is you
know according to some theories this one
is the building blocks of emotion
suffice to have balances yeah
they have avoidance in approach yeah and
those things can be studying in flies as
well that's a very very primordial look
at it yeah at emotion like or dislike
yeah go towards or go away from yeah
yeah flies also have another aspect of
the motion which is about arousal so
they some of the some of the Flies can
be highly aroused some of them can be
more like calm and those things we do
have a lot of behavior evidence for that
and those things can be studied in
Drosophila as well yeah
surveillances arousal the two building
blocks of elementary emotions can
actually be accessible in just a flat
Wow
so in addition to all the cognitive
studies that we're doing right now
throughout this conversation I'm just
frequently just trying to see how your
analysis of the Drosophila is related to
my like ideas about how those
potentially those neural correlates to
human behavior and my mind has just been
racing about how is it possible that we
also do these courtships or these
aggressions or these emotions these like
or dislikes and how can we start saying
this is hard because how many neurons
again arm the hundred thousand right in
the brain that's our rough estimation
throughand a hundred thousand neurons in
the drosophila about 70 to 80 million in
the rodent in the mouse and then 80
billion or more in a human brain and we
maybe think that it's possible that a
circuitry of like or dislike something
as simple as that could have even though
it may only be a network of like a
thousand or a couple thousand neurons in
this awful lot there could be an analog
to like or dislike of maybe tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands in
the human brain yeah
yeah yeah so I'm just like go the
research is so cool
and there's obviously great importance
to this also this catalog like if
there's a literally like a type-a social
interaction that leads towards like
higher success in courtship and you can
like watch that through video and hear
it in audio like there's oh like there's
a specific song style that leads to
greater success in courtship then you
can simulate that song style to win the
Drosophila stead and then watch as the
neural activity is in flow yeah yeah
maybe towards maybe towards a higher
propensity form desire for copulation
yeah and then we can maybe say that
there is a possibility that that same
thing exists when when like a female
identifies a human female identifies a
human male that is maybe a little bit
higher up on the hierarchy maybe has a
little bit more financial success or has
advanced a career in a certain degree
there's maybe a greater amount of desire
for mating with that then if the male is
lower on the hierarchy and so you can
maybe map a neural correlate of a
greater amount of activation that
happens yeah
I'm so fascinated with this subject this
is such an interesting one
okay so let's um let's have you explain
also the the overall like differences in
communication modalities can you list
them one more time for us you're doing
visual you know auditory s'matter
sensory somatosensory meaning like touch
touch yeah you know how about this one
too much but so the fruit flies also
come up and right they do touchy they do
tattoos now yeah you take hens they do
they shake they change they can't no way
with their little insect legs exactly
they yeah yeah yeah what mm-hmm yeah but
if there's but if there's friendship
there's or a courtship they will like do
a little like handshake literally like
that yeah like the leg shape yeah they
do
yeah in sick leg shape exactly yeah
what's very frequently happens yeah okay
so okay visual auditory somatosensory
there's also all faction and gas station
we don't specifically study those things
okay but there is smell or factory smell
and taste and taste yes would you call
JIT just gas station gas station yeah at
the station yeah it's interesting
okay okay
so what happens this sensory Medallia
yeah we do yeah these are basic sensory
modalities that have been evolutionary
conserved across many many different
species and it's very important that we
study information integration in the
central brain so my lab doesn't study
say visual processing improve your River
process and say in the retina which is
optic lobe in the flagrant or periphery
auditory or a factories processing eye
and we don't study that we just studies
and the higher order processing
essential brand especially information
integration and decision making things
like that a main takeaway it seems like
from this conversation is also that it's
important to in a sense humble ourselves
with how many different modalities of
communication we use visual auditory
somatosensory olfactory etc with us and
then I'm basically out of the ten
million species on the planet that
there's also different modalities of
communication between all of those
species and with specific hierarchies of
decision-making involved in why they're
communicating in those specific ways and
so it's basically this massive open
catalogue that we have yet to really
investigate into that year at the
frontier of investigating into and
you're doing it with one species the
dress offal and there's so many other
species of course the dress off though
is one of the best
scientific species for us to model
system the model system a model system
like the zebrafish yeah rodent serves
model systems Wow
they're like little like gifts of nature
like little hacks that make it easier
for us to yeah yeah it's easier because
there's a community of genetics study
for more than 100 years for Morgan time
that really allow us to dissect the
nervous system of the brain of a already
relatively simple brand almost one cell
at a time so this is really unparalleled
in any other species say zebrafish or
rodents because you don't have such a
great raft of our genetic tools yeah
yeah the once you have like the entire
cell lineage of an animal and also the
or an insect and then also the entire
connectome of the of the nervous system
then it becomes a model more of a model
and also it has high transgenic
abilities it has high reproduction rates
all the same would make it yeah um
another thing that I think is really
important for you to teach about is that
you know a lot of people are wondering
okay like if you're gonna be recording
all of this video all of this audio all
of the somatosensory interactions trying
to make catalogs of all of them it's
obviously a tremendous amount of data
mmm you've got probably trying to store
like petabytes of data of fruit fly
interactions yeah yes yes so and then
all so the question is how do you how do
you how do you in your lab effect like
if most effectively store that data and
most effectively analyze that data so
you have to do all this digital signal
processing of like audio and
video yeah so how do you guys do that
part yeah we use the ladies tools from
machine learning to do video analysis
audio analysis we invest a lot of the
hardware infrastructure computational
storage infrastructure and many of the
graduate students actually come from
engineering background say computer
science Electrical Engineering things
like that so really the way the modern
your sound system your science is
studied takes a shape that's slightly
different from traditional microbiology
so your science system your science
really focus on information processing
is it like assigning variables to
different from flies right so let's make
it easy proof like a b c yeah in the
chamber and be at a very specific time
stamp makes an audio transmission to
fruit fly seed is that how you're
approximately right yeah that's exactly
what we do so we try to do record the
video Nadya simultaneously and then we
do the analysis and we do the
synchronization so that we know at each
specific time what are the states for
specific flies so so among the different
flies in the chamber say what we pick
one of the Flies is a flight of interest
and we by doing this analysis we know
all the sensory information the contacts
the social context that available to
this fly of interest right and that's
what the brand is about to process and
if we get the statistical signature of
that state and we can try to
recapitulate that statistical structure
with desert with more controlled
programmed stimulation
so we can generate hypothesis wow I'm
doing that okay so I observe um
fruit fly be making an audio
transmission to fruit fly see and then
you record that exact transmission and
then maybe you also saw that that
transmission was the song and then B
approach C NC slowed down enabling B and
C to go through a copulation process
maybe then you take one of those two
fruit flies into the tethered
environment and then you and then you re
you simulate what you initially logged
as that process of be making a song
maybe you take C into the tethered
environment and you simulate bees audio
stream and then see how C's neural
architecture responds and then that's
maybe what you're trying to develop is
the toilets okay and there's ten people
right now in the lab yes right yes and
all of the ten in the lab are analyzing
their own data building their own data
analysis to write basically yes yeah
which is really cool I thought when you
were teaching me this I was like that's
a pretty good way to run the lab so
everyone's kind of gaining the this
experience of knowing how to do the data
analysis which is such an important part
is right he's doing that that way they
can all go and also do their own
experiments more easily immature and
right yeah you're training people really
well yes that's that's thank you yeah
yeah and then um we will you tell us
what's available from your lab like if
other people from around the world are
interested in collaborating with you
what parts of your techniques are
available for like non-commercial use
yeah now we don't have any specific
commercial interest at the moment
we develop and use tools for behavior
for anatomy and physiology including
functional imaging and back to
physiology and many of those tools
actually available yeah for flies are
people especially for people are over
here on Joseph wrote of course so the
scientists that are using that are
trying to study for non-commercial
purposes are able to get in touch to
potentially right where I should
distribute say transgenic flies reagents
for recording the activity says that G
cans a GT say G chem seven flies we
distribute it across many many places
people get that prior to publication
actually yeah ok so your G camp seven is
what you have to you have to transgenic
ly add G camp seven and that in name I
decide the genome of the fly to make
them transgenic fly that Express making
camp seven modify the genetics of the
fruit flies so that they express G camp
seven which enables the electrical
activity to fluoresce yeah for when you
image it right yeah yeah it's true
dynamics we didn't do that for very
specific neurons say one or two neurons
in the brain we can do that with as
little as just one or two of the neurons
out of the hundred thousand to fluoresce
right yeah that's really great okay so
you can distribute that so people can
ask for those see that yeah cool okay
okay what would be your ideal
neuroscience tool of the future maybe
like fifty or a hundred years down the
line what would be an ideal tool that
would let you do the reading of the
whole connectome do the manipulation to
the connectome like what would be an
ideal neuroscience tool for you yeah I
think along the lines of functional
imaging there's a lot more to do in
terms of the spatial and temporal
resolution and the spatial and temporal
scale
so council imaging the jg chem-7 series
allow us to do recordings across many
styles a pretty high resolution across a
pretty long time but that's not enough
we wanted to go into say more than one
kilohertz a second in terms of temporize
mission we want to record from every
cell ideally from every branch of the
dendrite across the brain and want to do
that
say across the entire life of the animal
so that's the ideal - I mean that
probably is not just one - it's probably
a whole combination of tools including
optical instrumentations including the
molecular tools and the probes and
including technologies for data analysis
yeah I think those are well I would like
to see him say one or two decades later
yeah how do you think we can inspire
more people around the world to work
together
education I think I think the people
across the world to come from very
different cultural background religious
background and there's a lot of barriers
between different groups of people but
there are also some general principles
general beliefs that are held by
everyone in the world and those things
can be educating and people could be
educated understand to realize that
actually people from entirely different
background actually they have a lot more
in common than they stop I think this is
a message and that should be delivered
you know probably by the mass media than
what they're doing now which is more
emphasis about the differences of group
between different communities yeah
yeah I like that answer a lot what do
you think is a skill that young people
should know as we go into the
exponential technology age this skill
there's a whole lot of different scale
I wouldn't emphasize specific skill of
rozzers but I do believe that
information technology is something that
are critically important for next next
generations
as you know this is a most rapidly
developing one of the most rapidly
developing that reaction and information
technology I would consider near science
is near Sciences are part of this
misdirection of information dispersion
yeah what would you say is the meaning
of life this big human experiment that's
happening yeah how to make sense of the
world and to make sense of ourself I
think that's from me the meaning of life
I like that answer
yeah making sense of our reality and our
selves yeah I like that a lot
what do you think is the role of love in
our world Wow Wow is like a glue right
it's kind of sticking putting things
together like well you your first
question about how people across the
world could collaborate more and love is
important ingredient because you know
love as we say is actually part of the
emotional system right so it can
modulate the brand and modeling or
behavior in a way that in the absence of
love are entirely different yeah yeah do
you think that this is a simulation
which one our reality becomes definition
of reality and simulation you know for a
neuroscientist we do better reality all
the time with tricks animal to believe
what actually uh not reality virtual
reality so I think it really is just
about inflammation processing
information the branding focusing
outside we perceive the outside world
through simulations in our brand so you
can say simulations reality and reality
simulation mmm and last question is what
do you think is the most beautiful thing
in the world the brain is the most
beautiful thing in the world
and the society is that a composed of
the brains if you the one that comes
after ya and why it's just amazing no
reason I love it I love it this has been
so mind-expanding be thank you very much
for coming over to our show thank you
thank you having thank you so much holy
cow
Wow everyone thank you very much for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking have more
conversations with your friends families
co-workers people online about the
neural mechanisms of social cognition
about all of these different things that
you was teaching us reporting electro
activity through fluorescence pioneering
novel methods and functional brain
imaging optimizing ways of imaging
physiology the neural mechanisms social
cognition in general internal
representations and the different
communication modalities for biology
just really think about this these
topics more and have more conversation
with your friends about them check out
the links in the bio below to ease work
in Westlake University and also support
the artists the entrepreneurs the
organizations around the world do you
believe in support simulation so we
continue doing cool things like coming
on site to Westlake University in China
interviewing great professors and
principal investigators like you you
then go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon peace
Wow
thank you oh my gosh so mind-blowing
they ask a lot of tough questions that I
wasn't prepared at all